does Rachel's Thanksgiving trifle truly  taste like feet  let's find out it's a trifle and it's  got all of these layers first there's a  layer of ladyfingers then a layer of jam  then custard which I made from scratch  then raspberries more ladyfingers than  beef saute with peas and onions then a  little bit more custard and then bananas  and then I just put some whipped cream  on top  [Music]  get some  beef and onion and peas and jam and  raspberries all in one bite don't forget  the banana oh my  [Music]  you know I got a side with Joey on this  one it's kind of good beef good there's  like a small hint  of weirdness you're not even past it  Kudos Rachel